[Applaus]
so und diese Woche ist was total
verrücktes passiert ich war gespannt auf
eine Rede von Olaf Scholz ja Wahnsinn
Regierungserklärung zur großen
Haushaltskrise sie wissen schon die
blöde Sache mit den Milliarden die jetzt
irgendwie weg
sind ja weil der buchungstrick vom Olaf
angeblich illegal war wobei
Regierungserklärung ist natürlich
Quatsch er regiert ja gar nicht und
erklärt hat er auch
nichts total Ausfall die Rede im
Bundestag Null Demut keine einzige
konkrete Idee wie es jetzt weitergehen
könnte dieser Kanzler schafft es ja
nicht mal mehr die eigenen Leute zu
begeistern wie das Gesicht von parteichf
Lars Klingbeil hier anschaulich
unterstreicht und stellt das vor
Herausforderung wie unsere Republik sie
in dieser Konzentration und Härte wohl
noch nicht erlebt
hat
ja dieser Moment wenn Dir klar wird mit
welchem Kanzler du demnächst wieder
Wahlkampf machen musst der klingball
warum hat der Scholz nicht wenigstens
einmal kurz sorry gesagt keine Ahnung
blöd gelaufen mein Fehler ich bin beim
Grundgesetz googeln auf der Maus
ausgerutscht irgendwas irgendwas
Fehlanzeige stattdessen zitiert der Mann
seine alten Hits und der Bundestag
schmeißt sich weg wir lassen niemanden
her akell so zu tun
[Applaus]
haben jetzt nicht Spa interpretieren
soll aber vielleicht ja
so chran
dem also das ist vielleicht kein so
guter
[Applaus]
Einfall körperliche Schmerzen bei den
versel
dan
die reichen nur noch bis zum 31 Dezember
selber schuldampel das passiert wenn man
alle Warnungen zu Sondervermögen in den
Wind schlägt jetzt steht man da blamiert
und ratlos peinlich ist wirklich
peinlich ja für den für den Haushalt
4 müssen mindestens 17 Milliarden
gefunden werden und wo genau das Geld
für die überfällige Modernisierung von
Infrastruktur und deutscher Wirtschaft
herkommen soll das weiß keiner
Schuldenbremse reformieren ja nein
vielleicht nur bei meine Leiche wo ist
denn bei denen noch die Schnittmenge
aber wie sagte schon der Scholz von 2019
aber müsste nicht eine Regierung eine
gemeinsame Vision haben
nein ach so na dann alles gut würde ich
sagen ja in Umfragen ist die Mehrheit
der Deutschen gegen eine Reform der
Schuldenbremse gut das liegt natürlich
auch daran dass viele Menschen private
und öffentliche Schulden gleichsetzen
jetzt ist es aber so
Investitionen in Bildung oder in Brücken
über die man regelrecht fahren kann sind
kein Verbrechen an kommenden
Generationen im Gegenteil ganz im
Gegenteil trotzdem kämpft Christian
Lindner einsam weiter für seinen Glauben
den Glauben an die eine große
Schuldenbremse ja es ist
wirklich es ist wirklich eine einzige
Leidensgeschichte meine Damen und Herren
kein Wunder dass der Koalitionsausschuss
am Mittwoch ergebnislos auseinander
gegangen ist ich kann es mir bildlich
vor stellen wie das war die SPD will
eine neue Notlage die Grünen ein
Sondervermögen Klima und dann steht
Lindner auf und ruft wo bleib eigentlich
ich wo bleibe eigentlich ich mit meinen
Sorgen ja ist ja gut du darfst dein
Dienstwagen Privileg ja behalten mein
Gott selbst konservative Ökonomen sagen
heute
1,5% Neuverschuldung vom
Bruttoinlandsprodukt wären für ein Land
wie Deutschland überhaupt kein Problem
und eine ganz andere Frage wo bleibt
eigentlich die Selbstkritik von Herrn
Lindner meine der hat schließlich auch
mitgetrixst Konsequenzen keine wobei gut
sein Staatssekretär Werner Gatzer wurde
in den Ruhestand geschickt und ich sage
sehr gut sehr gute
Entscheidung der hat sich das nämlich
ganz alleine ausgedacht mit den
Sondervermögen wissen viele gar nicht
aber Werner Gatzer ist schuld an alle
meine Damen und Herren wer Hattin Armin
lasch nach der Flut Imal den Witz
erzählt der in die Kanz gekostet hat
ganz genau Werner Gatzer wer hat kurz
vor Corona im chinesischen wan aus Spa
ein Gürteltier mit einer Fledermaus
gekreuzt der Gatzer Werner Gatzer hatte
die verfassungswidrige Idee Kai harards
gegen Österreich als Linksverteidiger
aufzustellen er hat jetzt sogar in den
Duden geschafft mit dem neuen Werb
vergatzen Steigerung von versemmeln
Beispielsatz Mann das habe ich ja mal
wieder voll vergatzt ja wirklich sehr
praktisch Don Sündenbock sollten Sie
auch mal versuchen in den Umfragen geht
der immer weiter Berg ab für die Ampel
und für den Kanzler Chef einer Regierung
die es wahrscheinlich nie hätte geben
dürfen die nie eine Gemeinsamkeit hatte
außer Geld das jetzt auch weg ist ich
fürchte liebe Zuschauer da können nur
noch wir Bürger helfen denn zum Glück
gibt es ja seit 2006 das
schuldentilgungskonto des Bundes so und
da kann jeder von uns das jetzt kein
Witz jeder von uns kann da Geld für den
Bundeshaushalt Spenden ja ja letztes
Jahr sind so
50.000 €
zusammengekommen bei 83 Millionen
Deutschen wie geizig seid ihr
denn dieser Finanzminister wurde von
skupellosen Verfassungsrichtern um all
sein Erspartes gebracht heute kann er
sich nicht mal mehr Wahlspots in Farbe
leisten schauen Sie also nicht weg und
spenden sie an ein Herz für Lindner wenn
jeder Deutsche nur ein € gibt dann
reicht das nicht mal ansatzweise ist ja
nur 1 € se seid ihr blöd aber schon bei
714,28 pro Nase wä Lindners 60
Milliarden Loch komplett gestopft der
Minister nimmt noch bis Heiligabend ihre
Spenden am Telefon entgegen und denken
Sie dran du kannst was tun du du du sie
zu Hause am Fernsehen sie können was tun
eben schauen wir nicht weg das macht ja
schon Olaf
Scholz sehr gute Aktion sehr gut gerade
jetzt
Vorweihnachtszeit
so machen wir uns bitte nichts vor der
allerletzte Vorrat an Gemeinsamkeiten in
dieser Ampel ist aufgebraucht aber sie
regieren trotzdem weiter um weiß ich
nicht um weiter zu regieren um um
Neuwahlen zu verhindern bisschen dünn
als Vision angesichts der
Herausforderung unserer Zeit aber ich
sag mal so große Ambitionen kommen hier
ja eh aus der Mode in diesem Sinne
herzlich Willkommen
zu News Deutschland gibt auf mit Valerie
niehhaus guten Abend über Jahrzehnte
waren wir der Streber Europas jetzt
beweist eine Meldung nach der anderen
Deutschland arbeitet endlich an einer
gesunden Work Life Balance aktuelles
Beispiel die Post bisher mussten 80% der
Briefe am nächsten Werktag zugestellt
werden laut einem neuen habeckgesetz
dürfen bald 95% am dr und 99
erst am vierten Werktag ankommen Zitat
damit ist die Zustellung am vierten Tag
quasi
sicher die Menschen sind quasi
begeistert aber es ist so wie immer sie
kommen gar nicht auch Rentner Volk ist
nur noch sauer ich habe die Schnauze
voll zurecht Zustellung erst nach vier
Tagen so viel Zeit haben viele Rentner
gar nicht
mehr und wir schalten live zu
unseremorter Martin klempno in eine
Kölner
Postfiliale ja Valerie hier beginnt der
Vorweihnachtsstress verzweifelte
Menschen versuchen ihre Pakete abzugeben
einige kampieren hier seit Tagen aus
Angst davor ihren Platz in der Schlange
zu verlieren in dem Zelt da vorne wird
gerade ein Baby
[Applaus]
geboren ja auch hier schlägt der
Fachkräfte mange gnadenlos zu nur
einchalterst mit einem Menschen
besesetetzt nebenan arbeitet die KI und
beantwortet Kundenbeschwerden so jetzt
muss ich doch schnell mal die
Gelegenheit nutzen und das
Weihnachtspaket für meine Mutter
loswerden neue Regel jeder der bei uns
ein Paket auf giibt muss fünf Pakete
ausliefern wir haben keine Zusteller
mehr aber Moment mal das geht nach Peru
nicht mein Problem
nächster vielen Dank Martin das neue
Motto lautet warum die Performance
verbessern einfach die Anforderungen
senken passend dazu auch diese Meldung
in Deutschland fehlen jetzt offiziell
430.000 kitapätze heißt auch bei der
frühkindlichen Förderung haben wir
aufgegeben dazu Bildungsministerin stark
Watzinger na und dove Kinder sind doch
auch
süß nächstes Beispiel unser Stromnetz
ist leider noch nicht bereit für all die
E-Autos und Wärmepumpen jetzt könnte man
mit Hochdruck alles tun um dieses Netz
schnell auszubauen
man rationiert Strom ab Januar in
bestimmten Krisenlagen möglich und wir
schalten mal live zu Martin klemno in
einen Kölner Baumarkt wo sich
dramatische Szenen
abspielen ja Valerie die Leute haben da
einiges falsch verstanden fakt ist ab
Januar dürfen Netzbetreiber die
Stromabnahme von Wärmepumpen und
privaten Ladestation vorübergehend
einschränken wenn dem Stromnetz
Überlastung droht trotzdem Bunkern die
Menschen jetzt wie blöde Kerzen weil sie
denken hab dreht ihn das Licht ab die
brennholzabteilung ist schon komplett
geplündert und jetzt stürzen sich die
ganzen Bildleser auf die letzten Kerzen
ich sag's noch mal deutlich es gibt
keinen
[Applaus]
kerzenmangel vielen Dank Martin wir sind
derartig im Arsch griechische Politiker
machen sich schon lustig über unsere
Haushaltskrise verkauft doch eure Inseln
ihr Pleite deutschen heißt es da die
Ampel in Berlin war kurz beleidigt und
hat dann SL bei Ebay
reingestellt Kommentar Olaf Scholz wer
Christian Lindner mit abholt kriegt
Amrum gratis
dazu Deutschland die drittgrößte
Industrienation der Welt wird inzwischen
ganz offen gedisst gestern z.B unser
Bundespräsident kommt in Katar an und
steht dann eine halbe Stunde in der
Flugzeugtür weil die K har vergessen
haben ihn abzuholen wie so ein nerviger
thermomixvertreter den man nicht
reinlassen will wahrscheinlich steht er
da immer noch und ja ich habe mich
abgeschminkt na und wenn alle sich
aufgeben mache ich das auch gute
Nacht breaking news
Deutschland die Welt wird immer rechter
aber eigentlich macht das gar nichts
denn sie geht ja bald unter seit gestern
ist mal wieder Klimakonferenz Kop 28 in
Dubai unter dem offiziellen tagungsmotto
da sind wir Dubai das ist
Klima oder so ähnlich fragen Sie die
Höhner ich weiß nicht der größte
Weltklimagipfel aller Zeiten mit über 70
000 Teilnehmern darunter auch eine XXL
Delegation aus Germany wir schicken
254 deutsche Delegierte in die Wüste ein
wie ich finde schönes sparsignal
angesichts der aktuellen Haushaltskrise
Klimaschützer sagen das ist der
wichtigste giipfel seit Paris und sie
hoffen dass in Dubai der Ausstieg aus
den fossilen Energieträgern eingeleitet
wird das halte ich persönlich für extrem
unwahrscheinlich und zwar aus Gründen
der diesjährige koppräsident Sultan
Ahmed aljab ist gleichzeitig
Geschäftsführer der zwöl größten
Erdölgesellschaft der
Welt ja gut es hätte auch die elftgrößte
sein können ich will wirklich nicht
unken aber mit dem Mann den sie Sultan
nennen als Konferenzleiter könnte es
eventuell einen minimalen
Interessenskonflikt geben ein Ölmanager
leitet ein Klimagipfel Wahsinn ja
in in Dubai haben sie gestern immerin
einen neuen Fond für Klimaschäden
beschlossen und die Umsetzung des
Pariser Klimaabkommens von 2015 wird
erstmals begutachtet kann man mal machen
nach 8 Jahren und wie läuft so die CO2
Konzentration in der Atmosphäre ist seit
der ersten un Klimakonferenz 195 stetig
gestiegen ja haben Wissenschaftler jetzt
herausgefunden Pläne machen und Pläne
umsetzen sind wohl doch zwei völlig
verschiedene Dinge schade Olaf Scholz
wirbt heute in Dubai für seinen
klimaclub der
ergeizigen indem er selber gar kein
Mitglied sein dürfte nein nein wirklich
nicht Deutschland bläst mehr CO2 raus
als Frankreich und Spanien zusammen
unser Geheimnis die Kraft der braunk
ja satirisch zugespitzt wir setzen ja
auch auf flüssig Gas das
Oberverwaltungsgericht berlinbrandenburg
hat gestern erst die Klimaschutzpolitik
der Ampel abgewarscht und zwar heftig ja
gut me beim Klima lernen wir halt alle
ständig dazu wer hätte z.B schon in den
70ern ahnen können was uns da heute
blüht und die Experten haben ausgerechn
dass wenn diese Tendenz weitergeht der
Temperaturanstieg in der Atmosphäre der
durch iche temperaturentieg bis zum
Jahre 2050 etwa 2 bis 3° betragen
wird okay Captain Iglu hat's damals
schon gewusst
einverstanden Kop 28 in Dubai im wieder
mal wärmsten Jahr seit Beginn der
Messung und nach einer Kette von
extremwetterereignissen der neueste un
Klimabericht hat gerade erst
festgestellt dass wir stramm auf 3°
Erderwärmung zusteuern vielleicht wä es
mal ehrlich uns von den 1,5 offiziell zu
verabschieden meine Damen und Herren
1,5°ziel es war schön mit Dir auch wenn
wir nie wirklich geglaubt haben dich je
erreichen zu können ja bis auf diese
doofen Kinder aber die glauben ja auch
dass sie später eine Rente kriegen ja es
hätte klappen können mit dir wenn wir
viel schneller viel mehr Windräder
gebaut hätten aber das ging ja nicht
wegen diesem rot Milan dumme Sau also
mach's gut 1,5° Ziel in alter ZDF
Tradition fahren wir dich jetzt mit
einem Bagger in die bedeutungs keit
[Applaus]
tschüss tschüss
1,5° vielleicht müssen wir das
Verabschieden so es ist ja völlig klar
es ist uns allen klar wir müssten viel
mehr machen lenken uns aber lieber ab
z.B mit der Wut auf die letzte
Generation wobei es einem diese Leute
auch manchmal etwas zu leicht machen sie
nicht zu mögen ich sage nur Farbanschlag
aufs Brandenburger Tor bin auch sicher
dass das als abwaschbare Farbe gekauft
wurde und hat sie sich halt als
hartnckig herausgestellt es ist jetzt
Buntsandstein und diese orangegelbe
Farbe gefällt mir ganz gut ich verstehe
gar nicht warum das so ein Aufreger
ist ich verstehe gar nicht warum uns
alle doof finden es ist wirklich ein
Rätsel ja das passiert wenn man zu viel
Farbe einartmet liebe Kinder so der
Klimaschutz hat allerdings ganz andere
Sorgen Abstumpfung das ist die größte
Gefahr wir stumpfen ab bei all den
wiederkehrenden Alarmmeldungen die ja
stimmen und man müsste auch mal
außerhalb von langweiligen
Nachrichtensendung über das komplexe
Thema Klima reden z.B auch im reality TV
warum denn nicht e Jerome wusstest du
laut Weltklimarat müssten die Emissionen
im Jahr 2030 bereits 43% niedriger sein
als 2019 korrekt aber es werden wohl 9%
mehr schöne Scheiße ja Frage ey wenn
diese Insel hier untergeht wo bitte
sollen wir dann bumsen neu bei RTL plus
love Island knattern bis der Eisberg
schmirzt ja warum denn nicht einfach mal
andere neue Schichten an das Thema
heranführen so meine dam Herren und ich
begrüße nun Christian ehing denn er
fliegt morgen auch nach Dubai und zwar
als Lobbyist der fossilen Industrie Herr
Ering warum ist Ihre Branche da
überhaupt vertreten ja ich weiß Clemen D
geht ja auch nicht so Weihnachtsfeier
vom Tierschutz Verein oder Bernt höcke
zur
antifah ne wir wollen natürlich wissen
was da besprochen wird in Dubai weil wir
auch so ein Stück weit das Gefühl haben
bei diesen Klimagipfeln hat sich in
letzter Zeit irgendwie so eine negative
Stimmung gegen uns aufgebaut ja das
könnte gut sein ich meine die großen
Firmen fahren ihre Öl und Gasförderung
gerade massiv hoch mal ernsthaft wer
lädt euch zu sowas ein ihr seid doch das
Problem ja wie LT uns ein da kommt
praktisch jeder rein allein letztes Jahr
bei 27 in Ägypten saßen mindestens 636
Vertreter der Öl und Gasindustrie mit am
Tisch der damalige Chef von BP war auch
da als kein Witz Vertreter von
Mauretanien also das ist überhaupt kein
Problem ich z.B ich geh dieses Jahr als
Schwede merkt keiner Nein Dubai wird
sowieso der beste Gipfel ever weil er
diesmal ein Lobbyist den ganzen Bums
leitet dr Sultan
alultanultan wir brauchen Öl und Gas und
Solar und Wind und Atom und Wasserstoff
alles
davon eben es ist doch alles Energie
warum jetzt Öl und Gas rausgeiben und
sagen das sind die bösen ich fin es auch
diskriminierend
Öl hat ja auch Gefühle ja letztes Jahr
in charmake habt ihr es sogar
geschafft als Brückentechnologie in die
Abschlusserklärung von einem Klimagipfel
reinzuschreiben gut die Erklärung lag
darum da schreibt man halt was
rein unsere Forschung sagt übrigens ganz
klar man kann Öl und Gas ruhig weiter
verbrennen wenn man gleichzeitig CO2 aus
der Atmosphäre saugt und in der Erde
speichert wä das nicht toll Herr welke
wenn jede Fabrik ihr CO2 speichern
könnte wie so ein
Baum ja aber das ist doch gar nicht so
ja aber das wä doch
toll sicher im Moment ist Carbon
capturing im großen Stil noch totale
Zukunftsmusik aber reden wir doch lieber
mal über die waren Probleme die
eigentliche Umweltsau ist doch gar nicht
die fossilindustrie
[Musik]
sondern er hier ich ich bin die
Umweltsau ja klar also stellvertretend
für den Verbraucher an sich sie sehen
mir aus wie einer der drei vier Mal die
Woche den alten Gasgrill anschmeißt und
halbes drauf wirft oder na oder das will
ich nicht völlig ausschließen aha
überführt übrigens auch eine tolle
Erfindung unserer Marketingabteilung die
Kollegen von BP haben in den 80ern
dieses Konzept vom individuellen CO2
Fußabdruck erfunden seitdem ist
Klimawandel ein persönliches Problem man
könte sagen ihre Schuld sie haben es
verbockt welke ja es tut mir auch total
leid ich kann trotzdem immer noch nicht
fassen dass hunderte Lobbyisten
Konferenzen unterwandern um den klimutz
auszubremsen ja wir unterwandern ja
nicht nur
Klimagipfel oder glauben Sie ernsthaft
die nervigen Fridays V future Blagen
wären alles echte
Aktivisten da ich aber eine ganz
schlechte Nachricht für
Sie how dare you und das
hier das ist für dein Fußabdruck du
Schwein Greta ehing meine Damen und
[Applaus]
Herren
haud die Leute ich wollte euch nur um
ein kleines Abo bitten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
na los ja los du scheißpferd
hey